The Tunguska Event
The Tunguska event occurred around 7:00 a.m.
local time on June 30, 1908 near the Podkamennaya
Tunguska River in Siberia.
Witnesses saw a “blue-ish light, nearly
as bright as the Sun, moving across the sky.”
What followed was an estimated 15 megaton
explosion which knocked over about 80 million
trees in about a 1300 square mile area, forming
a butterfly shape pattern.
This also sent a shock wave throughout parts
of Europe and Asia, registering as far away
as England (about 4000 miles away).
Further, the atmospheric pressure change was
also significant enough to be measured all
the way in Great Britain.
Another interesting side effect of this blast
was that, for several days after the blast
throughout most of Asia and Europe, the night
sky glowed.
It was so bright that people as far away as
China reportedly were able to read in the
middle of the night by nothing but the glow
of the sky.
For a firsthand account, here is the testimony
of one S. Semenov, who was about 40 miles
from ground zero:
“At breakfast time I was sitting by the
house at Vanavara Trading Post (65 km from
the epicenter), facing north…
I suddenly saw that directly to the north,
over Onkoul’s Tunguska Road, the sky split
in two and fire appeared high and wide over
the forest.
The split in the sky grew larger, and the
entire northern side was covered with fire.
At that moment, I became so hot that I couldn’t
bear it, as if my shirt was on fire; from
the northern side, where the fire was, came
strong heat.
I wanted to tear off my shirt and throw it
down, but then the sky shut closed, and a
strong thump sounded, and I was thrown a few
meters.
I lost my senses for a moment, but then my
wife ran out and led me to the house.
After that such noise came, as if rocks were
falling or cannons were firing, the earth
shook, and when I was on the ground, I pressed
my head down, fearing rocks would smash it.
When the sky opened up, hot wind raced between
the houses, like from cannons, which left
traces in the ground like pathways, and it
damaged some crops.
Later we saw that many windows were shattered,
and in the barn a part of the iron lock snapped.”
So what caused this massive blast?
For a long time, it wasn’t precisely known.
When the event first happened, it drew little
interest largely because it happened in a
very remote part of the world.
It wasn’t until some 19 years later that
Leonid Kulik, a Russian mineralogist, decided
to go investigate, figuring that a massive
meteorite must have hit the Earth.
Kulik and his team had little trouble locating
ground zero of the blast, despite it being
19 years later, due to the fact that the “trees
acted as markers, pointing directly away from
the blast’s epicenter”.
However, once they got to the epicenter, they
found a curious thing.
There was no crater, as they had expected,
and the trees were still standing in about
a 3 mile radius circle at the center, but
with their limbs, bark, leaves, etc. all completely
stripped.
So essentially, all these trees were just
giant poles in the ground with all the other
trees for miles and miles around blasted to
the ground.
For a long time, there was much debate over
exactly what caused this, but today scientists
are reasonably certain it was a comet, rather
than an asteroid (see the difference between
a comet and an asteroid) or other naturally
occurring event.
The comet must have been around 30-40 meters
across (around 120 feet) and must have been
traveling around 30,000-40,000 mph (about
55,000-65,000 km/h).
As it traveled through the atmosphere, the
air around it heated up to as much as 50,000
degrees Fahrenheit (about 28,000 degrees Celsius)
causing the comet to look like a giant fireball
streaking through the sky.
Eventually, this also caused the comet to
annihilate itself around 5 miles (8 km) above
the Earth’s surface in a fiery blast that
consumed the comet, which was largely made
of ice.
Thus, you get a massive explosion, but no
impact crater or much of any apparent evidence
of what caused the explosion, unless you witness
it or start taking very careful soil samples
and the like.
It wasn’t until nuclear testing that these
same blast patterns would be observed again,
including the stripping of trees around ground
zero with the other trees being blasted down.
What’ happening here is the shock wave travels
so fast that there is insufficient time for
the branches to transfer the force to the
main part of the tree before they are ripped
off.
For those trees in the epicenter, the force
is all downward, so the result is simply that
the branches and bark all get stripped, but
the trees remain standing.
Outside of the epicenter, the shock-wave hits
the trees at more of a horizontal angle, so
it flattens them.
Eventually, Soviet experimenters were able
to even mimic the butterfly blast pattern
with a model forest and small charges.
From this, they discovered that the blast
must have occurred with the blasting body
approaching at around a 30 degree angle from
the ground and 115 degrees from North.
It’s estimated that a Tunguska sized comet
or asteroid should hit the Earth’s atmosphere
about once every 300 years.
The blast from it is more than sufficient
to wipe out even the largest city on Earth,
should it happen to blow up or strike around
a major city.
A comet or asteroid about 1/3 of the size
of the Tunguska comet hits the Earth’s atmosphere
about one or more times per year and produces
a blast of around 20 kilotons, which is about
equivalent to the nuclear bomb dropped on
Nagasaki.
Luckily, these tend to annihilate themselves
quite high in the atmosphere.
In order to get the Soviet government to pay
for his expedition to go investigate this
blast, Kulik convinced them that it must have
been a meteorite and that meteorite would
have been massive and made mostly of iron,
so there was great potential for a huge supply
of easily minable iron available that the
Soviet’s could use.
The U.S. built a nuclear bomb that was roughly
equivalent to the Tunguska comet, in terms
of blast power, being rated at around 15 megatons.
This nuclear bomb was named Castle Bravo and
was detonated on March 1, 1954.
The Tsar Bomba (see video showing the detonation
below), the largest nuclear bomb ever detonated,
had a yield of around 50 megatons.
Originally, it was designed to have a yield
of 100 megatons, but was reduced due to concerns
over nuclear fallout.
Not only was it the largest nuclear bomb detonated,
but it was also one of the cleanest, relative
to the TNT equivalent output.
It was detonated on October 30, 1961.
The Hiroshima and Nagasaki bombs, on the other
hand, were very small compared to the Tsar
Bomba and were not that efficient.
The Hiroshima bomb was estimated at about
only 13 kilotons of TNT (1/3800th the size
of the Tsar Bomba) with the total blast destructive
zone only being about one mile in radius.
Including resulting fires, it destroyed about
5 square miles of the city or about 69% of
the buildings, killing 70,000 people upon
detonation with an additional 70,000 seriously
injured.
Around 90% of all medical staff and facilities
were destroyed in the explosion itself; that,
combined with the effects of radiation burns
and sickness, contributed to about an additional
150,000 people dead at various points thanks
to the blast, though many survived for years
to come before succumbing to cancer and other
such sicknesses brought on by heavy ionizing
radiation exposure.
Nagasaki, on the other hand, had significantly
less casualties, partially due to the fact
that conventional bombs were dropped on it
before hand, so many of the people, particularly
school aged children, were evacuated from
the city by the time the nuclear bomb was
dropped.
This explosion was 21 kilotons, with casualties
reaching a still staggering number of around
40,000 people instantly, with around triple
that number estimated overall.